we must we must start pushing on intent
we should fix our intent not our ability
to check the box
you got your perspective
[Music]
I'm about to talk to you about why I
believe kindness and empathy and and
every other great emotional intelligence
skill is the foundation to actually
build a great business financially money
and yet I'm the child of a father who
grow who grew up in the Soviet Union I
was born there as well came here when I
was three and when my dad eventually
achieved his American dream and owned a
liquor store when I was dragged into
that liquor store as a 14 year old my
dad sat me down and this is this
singular first piece of advice that I
heard in the real business world because
I was crushing it in lemonade stands and
baseball cards but this was the first
thing I had ever heard my dad and I are
driving to the liquor store my dad is
really in a lot of ways the reverse of
me which means he doesn't talk a whole
lot but he looked at me and before we
walked into the store he looked me dead
in the face and my dad's one of these
guys with like eyebrows that are
naturally in the mean position doesn't
speak and is from the Soviet Union and
looks me dead in the face and says to me
the employees are our enemies
he said son the only thing you have to
do today in the store is to make sure
you watch them so they don't steal and I
used to really hate be mad at and worst
of all judge my father for that and I
did that because I lacked empathy and
context and understanding that when
you're first twenty two years or in the
Soviet Union and communism owns
everything the entire world works with
the black market and everybody steals
and that's just how the ecosystem worked
but it's so full circle for me to have
the incredible luxury of being here
tonight and an honor because my natural
DNA was far more like my mother's I
genuinely believe that karma is
practical I wildly believe in optimism
to the point of delusion my greatest
weaknesses over the last 20 years in
running businesses has actually been
predicated in creating entitlement
because I care so much about EQ and
optimism and we can figure it out to the
point where no question my great regret
as a CEO for the last 20 years in two
different businesses with the success
that I've had is that there are people
walking around the world that I did the
wrong thing by because I love happiness
so much that I was unable to have the
gear of radical candor that is needed to
offset everything I'm about to talk
about however to this day I would much
rather have a culture of happy and safe
and entitled then wildly profitable and
dark and I believe we're sitting in a
very interesting time a time where in
culture in the macro we are pulling in
opposite directions thinking somehow
miraculously one way of doing things is
the right way and yet to achieve and
everything I'm about to talk about which
is 100% accountability recognizing that
us judging employees when we navigate
companies
based on a P&L is ludicrous and
audacious and unkind in a world where I
genuinely believe that you know actually
let me throw this in here this may help
frame it up when I think about
vaynermedia my current company 900
people global Singapore London New York
LA it's an agency tough game Client
Services is brutal it's a real rugged
game I believe that I've done a lot of
things wrong and a lot of things right
but I believe genuinely
that the reason the organization
continues to flourish is because we look
at it as the honey Empire honey over
vinegar there is no reason not to be
kind and compassionate the meta nature
of what transpired today in my
organization without going into him or
her today literally today my
organization fired one of the single
most productive financial employees in
our company for 100% reason of he is
just not a good communicator or che -
god damn it it's just not a good
communicator to people around him I I do
not know how to say this in any other
words than the following I believe that
technology advancements over the next
half century will prove out the
hypothesis that I will lay in front of
you which is the following making
decisions far more predicated around
people that have humility people that
have kindness generally likable people
drives bigger financial results period
end of story
and let us collectively look ourselves
in the mirror and understand that the
far majority of businesses that are in
corporate land are run by CFO's not CEOs
and let us accept that a CFO that she or
he has to navigate an organization to
make its payroll to hit its numbers I
think we judge there are many people
here in the HR person session you know I
for a long time called myself an HR
driven CEO you can watch videos of me in
2007 on the internet fad me
talking about that long before this was
cool long before this was in the
consciousness but it took me an
evolution to understand the thing I
opened with because I wanted to get
right to it which is I wasn't finding
the right balance it was a little bit
too much optimism I had to find the
cadence and now I navigate and more
importantly because I hate focus groups
of one I watch and analyze and look at
so many businesses I believe that you
can have both I believe that you can
have both I believe that there is an
unbelievably powerful opportunity for
businesses to have friction between the
CFO and as we call it at vaynermedia the
chief heart officer Claude silver holds
this position in my organization she is
my direct report not only that she is
the number two person within our
organization weekly monthly we sit and
have strategy people business meetings
where if her and the CFO do not see
eye-to-eye that tie goes to the runner
to her that is wildly unheard of in our
society today and much like most of the
things that I've had my hand in
historically it becomes correct is there
so much naivete at the Wall Street
Silicon Valley business alpha DNA to not
understand that retention and Happiness
leads to dramatic more results than
appeasing the best salesperson even
though they have a tornado and wipe out
everybody internally in their past
appreciate that sir because it's right
and actually I I have come to realize
something remarkable growing up in a
family liquor store business where your
business paid for your life so this was
not about awards or weird reports or
theory this was life and then going into
you know startup world where I invested
it was life to come into corporate land
over the last decade I am fascinated by
the ability of corporate America and
global corporate organizations to have
somehow systematically eliminated common
sense from the equation
hey guys sorry to interrupt your video
I'm just giving you this call for my
number to let you know that you have to
join my text community to one two nine
three one five seven three one hit me up
with a text if common sense had a place
in current big business we wouldn't even
need to talk about HR it's people it's
always gonna be people nobody's paying
more attention to blockchain and AI and
machine learning and all that than me
and I promise you it's going to be
people until the robots come along and
kill all of us which I think they might
it's going to be people we have to start
getting much smarter around hitting
costs letting go of somebody to hit a
number who's kind of something on the
numbers but is the beat the heart the
glue and that makes 12 other people want
to come to an organization that person
needs to be rewarded financially not
fired
[Applause]
and before this gets way to foofy-foofy
i want to remind everybody that i think
of my organization as the honey empire i
am out here to put everybody out of
business I want to win I want to build
the biggest company in the world I want
to buy the New York Jets and win a Super
Bowl and I not knowing anything about
the real world because I was a terrible
student and I was completely 100%
focused on the end consumer always
lemonade Sam's baseball cards the wine
business vaynermedia I don't even know
these conversations existed I don't even
understand what we're debating how can
you have an organization when the asset
is people where that is not the thing we
spend the most time and then I
understood Oh weird right because I was
a DNF student I'm not good at black and
white but I dominate gray I dominate
gray right people don't have the
emotional intuitive luck of the draw
some of you I'm looking around some of
you were just born really pretty some of
you are fast some of you are tall some
people just get it when it comes to
people and if you get it when it comes
to people you have to start leaning into
things like empathy compassion you have
to become much more thoughtful all our
political stuff right now
nobody's deploying any empathy to
anybody everybody's on tilt everybody's
on their point of view that's happening
in our society it's happening definitely
within the four walls of our
organizations and at the tippy top this
is just one bad game of Wall Street and
I'm not mad at Wall Street even though
I'm not mad I'm mad at games that have
to be played in every 90 day terms and
if you don't play within that 90 days
you become vulnerable it's very easy to
be the head of people and make decisions
around people and be mad at the CEO and
me mad at her but you're not the one on
a phone call with investors with on Wall
Street every 90 days explaining why
don't worry everybody who's put their
money
into us a lot of it good news I know
that our money looks real bad but
everyone's super happy most CEOs don't
have the luxury of having enough control
to let that play out and really manifest
within a decade most don't even care let
me promise you one thing if you have
some North Star of Nirvana of businesses
that really care about people and your
company in one way or another ladders up
to something that is publicly traded
please stand up and leave Dallas now I
mean that do not be naive and it's
there's nothing necessarily massively
wrong with that but delusional ideology
of the game you're actually playing
always leads to frustration it's just
the way it is you want to be 100%
centric around the people narrative go
become a weird Yoda in a cave in Peru
because if you're in a business that has
a P&L that has to hit numbers the other
parts gonna be part of the equation
but I argue that it has gone
ridiculously too far that in the
consolidation of corporate stuff and
good students that like numbers and
excel sheets we have lost so much of
what SMBs
and family businesses have run on which
is the nuances I out of sheer luck that
my parents had sex at the right moment
have the DNA that I pulled very hard
from both sorts I pull very hard from
both sides I will always choose long
term people because when I look at my
retention of my employees I realize the
speed in which they navigate through
knowing each other and most importantly
when you have an organization that has
limited amounts because you can't change
everyone's DNA and cynicism is really
cool but when you can suffocate and over
time eliminate fear from your
organization very good things happen if
employees didn't spend all their time
trying to
outmaneuver Karen because they're both
trying to kill each other politically
they might actually achieve the task at
hand this level of common sense and
human truth will play out I do not know
who the six-year-old girl in Tennessee
right now is that's going to invent the
system to score this but before I die
this will become mapable and we will
actually start the process of swinging
the other direction this is just the way
it's going to be if you are in the game
right now and do not realize that we
will continue to go down a process of
looking at the nuances of employees
leaders that can balance the yin and
yang of creating a culture an
environment and by the way since all the
leaders are here can we just stop
checking the boxes for the sake of
checking the boxes are we really going
to be a culture that Pat's ourselves on
the back for hitting a diverse for the
number really we must we must start
pushing on intent we should fix our
intent not our ability to check the box
that that's how we'll get to where we
all want to go this is not a sync issue
this is the well and we must have these
thoughtful conversations we just must
and so here's some random thoughts
because I want to bring as much value
there's a couple other things I wanted
to talk about I think the philosophy is
set we can get into the nuances I'm
happy to answer any of your comments on
social over the next 57 years but a
couple things just random I am
fascinated by hiring I am fascinated by
people's ego to think they're good at
hiring
[Laughter]
watching the world for some reason take
pride in an ability of framework my
favorite I got this one question that
helps you be good at hiring is laughable
at best and ludicrous at worst we must
start talking about hiring and firing in
a compassionate way to help
organizations we have so much ego
wrapped up in hiring so much waste so
much consensus agreement very hard to
make a decision when 47 people have
equal say we must start talking more
about hiring because guess what good
news the college gig it's coming to an
end the racket is almost over and it's
not gonna be so easy for you to hide
behind well she went to Yale we must be
more thoughtful but more importantly we
must look for other things than data
points in my career hiring I want to be
not over two top here 7000 people
I have called zero point zero references
I have no interest in calling your PR
person
[Applause]
if there is no bigger waste of time of
this collective room it is calling
somebody as a reference that they told
you to call you know how I know this
I've given the biggest references to the
worst employees that have ever worked
for me because I like them I don't want
them to be on the street I feel bad
literally taking somebody who's a 1 and
convincing the other person that there
are 96 don't figure it out we have so
many things to talk about in this world
that we all kind of live in number one
actually back to remember I'm glad I got
to this I forget so many things usually
improv has its strengths and weaknesses
this is very meta if you follow how many
people here to follow my content just
for context thank you okay it's great so
most don't so listen no no that's what I
thought there's a lot of people here
this is wild and if you don't know me
which is why I asked you may think it's
a plug but let me be very much on the
record LinkedIn Facebook YouTube the NFL
orange juice I have no emotion for
anything I care about nothing except the
end consumer
but with that preface there's a very
remarkable thing going on for the far
majority of people in this room for the
last year I've been yelling on LinkedIn
and many other platforms that LinkedIn
is a really good place to put content
right as we sit here today the far
majority of people's issue for their
business how many people own their
business or the CEO raise your hands
okay not that many you should consider
it it's fun I'm just kidding
but for the people that run marketing or
make decisions or influence decisions
LinkedIn over the last six months to a
year and I don't know when this
algorithm changes and when the supply
and demand of attention and content
changes which is what happens to all
these platforms my favorite police for
last four years Instagram is going
through it right now for all the biggest
content producers especially
personalities the organic decline has
just started said that they get nasty a
lot of influencers are gonna get a job
[Laughter]
anyway LinkedIn right now is going
through a Facebook 2012 moment you right
now have a business or trying to build a
profile or trying to communicate
something to the world have no followers
on LinkedIn produce content and the
organic reach and consumption is
remarkably high it will go away they
always do they went away on MySpace it
went away on Facebook
there it goes away everywhere its supply
and demand of attention so one thing I
definitely wanted to get across before I
got off here content
communication not your personal brand
think of it a different way your
reputation it matters a lot of you are
still trading on your reputation because
you've been doing it a long time
reputation is getting built at scale in
LinkedIn for b2b businesses which have
never really had a home for content like
they do now and just being obsessed with
over bringing value I implore you to dig
into this hypothesis get educated and
remember when you produce content you
don't have to do video you don't have to
do audio you don't have to do written
word as a matter fact my highest
over-indexing content on LinkedIn right
now is comic strips that I create from
the things I talk about in the feed it's
working
gifs memes you know unemotional about
how we communicate we used to draw in
caves people used to do smoke signals I
do not mind how people unlike the far
majority of this room in world I do not
judge how one wants to consume content I
just react to the truth and then that
truth at this moment not next year not
last year at this exact second there's a
huge arbitrage of organic reach within
LinkedIn that I have a funny feeling
will help you get something that you
want whatever that may be and oh by the
way as humans
where many of you may have your side
hustle if you're selling cupcakes or
your fitness program or hair extensions
LinkedIn which is wild watching it
become Facebook in there instead of just
b2b has been phenomenal so highly
recommend that that's another side note
let's talk about a couple other things I
think that there's a lot of weird things
about this industry for example I am
fascinated by the fact that people are
appalled by anonymous review websites
about your business that we have not had
the proper conversation about how it
actually works which is most companies
induce force scare people into leaving
positive reviews on this site and then
pay these platforms to hide the bad ones
and I'm confused by the crippled nature
of anonymous reviews anonymous reviews
always dwindle in their importance it's
human behavior the shadows lead to very
little good and more importantly I now
recommend for the HR world to go the
other way and feed these sites with
negative reviews allowing them to
eliminate candidates from applying who
don't have the emotional intelligence to
understand that anonymous reviews are
stupid
[Applause]
real life real life just look at the
business models of these companies and
answers all you need to know so that's a
random thought anyway that girl in
Tennessee is gonna figure out something
and what she's gonna do is figure out
the following story I can't believe how
well this worked out to me because that
following story actually Adam where are
you I saw your face hey brother I'm
literally looking at a former employee
who I ran in today to today who I fired
and during that firing which was a very
by the way a top-15 firing of my career
that was difficult because not only is
he a tremendous dude the timing of his
life with his family expansion made this
firing unbelievably difficult
coinciding with me now having to deploy
self-awareness which is fun to tell
other people to do and realize that I
was not doing a good enough job with
radical candor or putting people in a
position to succeed but as he told me
today which meant a lot to me brother
the most important thing that happened
there was enabling that individual
during this extremely tough time with
support and more importantly a framework
to deploy self-awareness the reason I
loved him so much is because I loved him
the job he was doing for him yeah not
that bad wasn't the best I am the CEO of
my company and don't have a prayer and
getting hired by it I do not have the
grammar skills nor the math skills to
ever be an employee of vaynermedia but I
can run it that level of self-awareness
must be talked about why did I bring up
that story I have no clue but I know how
I feel about him I have a funny feeling
over the last four years 5 years he's
navigated life I that my company has
grown in profiles since then I get my
name gets thrown around negative
positive but he was a human being that
gets to walk around earth know what
happened there know what I did after he
was there when he was there and I have a
funny feeling maybe I'm wrong that when
my knee gets brought up oh he's a dick
right that he might say actually let me
tell you a story I know how real life
works I know that the truth is
undefeated and I know that there's a lot
of hidden financial variables of the
humanity that my business runs on not on
its profitability I know that many of
those conversations have led to other
conversations that led to other
conversations that became the single
variable that some other human being
decided to do business with us or come
into our organization and work for us
and drive our business I am fascinated
by people's inability to play chess
around the interest of HR and continue
to play checkers how do we not
understand that what the person feels
like on the way out matters almost if
not more than how they feel while
they're there and so we thank you
[Music]
we need an uncomfortable paradigm shift
people are gonna clap and pat themselves
in the back all week here on tactics the
current state of what's accepted or what
we aspire to in tactics and we will come
back in two or three years or within our
organizations and we will show pie
charts of how we've done better yet we
will continue to live and operate within
frameworks where the financial health of
the business is 100% the decision-making
tree of the organization and until we
change that and until we change the
structure and until we give the ladies
and men on Wall Street the ability to
build businesses long term until we
understand that all these venture backed
companies have so much
inbound dollars that they're burning
their cash and if they don't raise more
capital
out of business and all they're really
trying to do is to go public or sell
their company so how could they actually
care about you until we have a
dramatically more thoughtful
conversation of the intent until we put
companies that are trying to build in
perpetuity at the top not the one that
flipped this week we will never achieve
we will never achieve the level of
humanity that we are looking for all
subconsciously within the four walls of
this organization and when will we
challenge hiring or my favorite reviews
that's a [ __ ] doozy and I know it
because I promised that my wouldn't
curse but I had to go there on this one
reviews you mean people that have
political invested interest making
judgment on the people below them to
subconsciously or worse consciously make
sure that they don't take their spot you
mean that one that's right can we just
get thoughtful can we just get
thoughtful and not that I have every
answer I spend so much time trying to be
Gary Vaynerchuk the human being to
offset Gary Vaynerchuk the CEO when I
look at reviews and this I spend on
godly hours following all my employees
and social media not to be a creeper but
do you know how many good decisions I've
made in last decade by understanding
who's friends with who in the
organization so I understand the best of
feedback you know how easy it is for
three employees to gang up on somebody
and create a narrative that gets that
person fired unless you're thoughtful
enough to know what I'm talking about I
know it's true and you know it's true in
all 5,000 people here know it's true and
all 1 million people that watch this
video at some point know it's true when
when is our industry willing to have the
actual conversation instead of digging
in to the surface level side that they
reside in that is the day we begin the
process of bringing good stuff to
businesses because they
both matter and they need friction but
we have to have the real conversation
not the easy one thank you thank you
guys so much thank you
[Applause]